Le'Veon time to wake up time to go to  the Steelers facility today it's time to  finally check in and be a good teammate  or we could never go back and watch them  suffer into the ground it's time to go  in and apologize to your teammates tell  them how much you missed football you  heard what they said about you those  offensive lineman how many touchdowns  that they scored James Connor you should  shave his head when you get the camp you  can be a part of a winner  this team can win the Superbowl levian  and you know what that means more  dollars we could buy so many jet skis  levy on a few in the Super Bowl  mutual funds with the extra money levy  on mutual funds